hey it's Alexis from tasty to get ready
for the season 10 premiere of MasterChef
I'm challenging myself to see if I can
recreate the winning dish from season
one fried chicken and creamy collard
greens let's get started this apron goes
to the individual that I think I mean
mature across this competition there's
no one else here so I'm become a true
master chef this is just for fun right
this apron belongs to I'm okay
I mean I'm frying chicken today so this
will come in handy I guess just kind of
cool for these creamy colored greens I'm
starting out with butter and shallots
so now that the butter is melted I can
add the shallots I like using shallots
more than onions because I think it has
a nicer flavor it can be kind of more
subtle now I'm ready for my collards you
know I feel like collard greens are kind
of underappreciated and underrated but
if you do it right they're delicious
time to cream talk to me a little bit
about what you're making
well actually I'm making the season one
master chef winning dish it's really
simple buttermilk pan-fried chicken with
creamy collard greens let's move on to
the chicken I'm gonna pound these
chicken breasts really thin it's gonna
get them to have a really nice crust
cook evenly but first I've got to pound
them out with a mallet take it serious
or take your apron off I'm not even in
the competition let me live let's get
one thing straight this is my kitchen my
rolls I'm gonna move on to my buttermilk
marinade a buttermilk marinade is a
really good way to tenderize the chicken
and make it really juicy and flavorful
which chicken breast kind of needs now
I'm gonna let these marinate for about
an hour
moving onto my drench so I've got flour
salt pepper you know you always want to
season whatever you're dredging garlic
powder garlic powder and onion powder is
something more for traditional home
cooks yeah and this is a show about home
cooks you've never used it
no never that's crazy I mean this is
only garlic powder but we're kind of
missing out the egg and milk are just
gonna help bind the flour to the chicken
so we got that really beautiful crust
ready to dredge so I've got my marinated
chicken going to add it to the flour
first and then into the egg mixture
[Music]
so this is nice and dredged so I just
want to get the temperature to 350 looks
like it's ready can get frying Wow
this is a really thin chicken breast
it'll cook for about seven minutes total
I want it to get really nice and golden
brown crispy on both sides I'm gonna let
it go for a few minutes I know the
judges are also going to taste with
their eyes so I really want it to be
this even golden brown all the way
through I'm going as fast as I can
chicken right on top and stop I'm done
oh that was crazy cooking a chicken
breast in seven minutes it's virtually
impossible is this one good yeah chef
how do you know that chicken is cooked I
mean I think it's fine I mean I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna actually just take
it for a minute okay I'll be back just
gonna hang out
it's cooked perfectly oh my God thank
you so much chef just from the outside
you got a beautiful color on it I think
you did a great job creating texture on
the outside there's a beautiful crust I
was not expecting this but I'll take it
thank you so much good chicken do you
think I can be on MasterChef okay got
the apron I'm ready
oh thank you so much chefs that was
actually surprisingly fun now if you
want to see the real home cooks compete
on season 10 of MasterChef tune into Fox
on Wednesday May 29th 8:00 7:00 central
[Music]
you